[Music]
now I vaguely would call some complaints
from Antonia Brown about never being
over at Ben Roethlisberger's house there
is a Derek Carr's house right out of the
gates the two new teammates getting
together and at his introductory press
conference on Wednesday Antonio Brown
had some positive things to say about
his new quarterback just refreshing I
think he's hungry for success hungry for
telling the organization around hungry
to get on the winning side of things and
I'm just hungry
for the same thing so I think we stand
for the same causes God Faramir our
family first type people you know we
just want to be the best crowd that is
Antonio Brown god-fearing family first
you know it's hard not to hear that and
wonder whether or not he's taking a
backhanded slap yeah Ben Roethlisberger
I think so yeah and you just wonder how
much of those comparisons are going to
be made obviously there's gonna be a
comparison made between the quality of
quarterbacks and I still continue to
think the Derek Carr is gonna face a ton
of pressure Antonio Brown talked about
accountability the accountability is
gonna land on the quarterback if Antonio
Brown isn't getting the kind of numbers
he's used to but Chris that leads to our
draft for today
best new teammate combinations and we
I'm set it was only here for a couple of
weeks it was like the McRib the
rock-paper-scissors is gone we're back
to the coin toss as always you get the
honors thank you sir thank you God rocks
paper scissor shoots done cuz that was
getting brutal but I'm going with tails
Thank You Kristen let's start it off
with a old tale shockingly he calls
tails do this why don't I just let you
take the first pick go ahead okay please
let's just do that for now let's let's
stop the theatrics and give me the first
pick I'm fine with that that's no
problem with me I mean this is kind of
Captain Obvious here okay I mean we know
what the first pick of this is are you
kidding me Odell Beckham jr. and Baker
Mayfield end the segment the drafts over
I won right there but come on I mean
these two how could you not be excited I
don't care if you don't like Odell
Beckham jr.
Baker Mayfield at the very least you got
an oh wow these are two special talents
with some personality and the talents
that they have on the field and if
you're watching it on TV right now you
can see them having a giggle in the
pregame at the preseason game of the
Giants and browns playing each other but
the thing that's awesome is not only
about the personalities which I think
all mesh is the skill sets mesh and man
Baker Mayfield you made the point
yesterday statistically is one of the
best down the field throwers in all of
football I think he was what forth and
football last year you know Odell
Beckham jr. is open is about as much as
anybody in football down the field so I
just see fireworks with this combination
let alone the other combinations along
with it
Jarvis Landry Antonio Galloway and Dave
and Joe goose oh this is awesome I'm
surprised you didn't go Aaron Rodgers
and Billy Turner go ahead you do it yeah
yeah not a shock that you would select
that you would select Odell Beckham jr.
and Baker Mayfield and you could really
throw Jarvis Landry in there is really a
great trio of teammates I'm gonna go
with one that I think is almost as
obvious as Oh BJ and Baker Mayfield it's
Sam Donald and his new we're all running
back Le'Veon Bell because it's gonna
elevate Donald's game Bell is rested
he's healthy he's a year removed from
playing he'll be fine and that's gonna
carry the Jets offense and it's gonna
lead that team to some potentially
exciting times and you know you look at
the newspapers in New York there's an
awakening now that the Jets are
eclipsing the Giants and you bring in
LaVey on bail at a time when the Giants
are shedding obj and that's gonna create
a sense that maybe the Jets can finally
become a consistent contender at least
as long as they have Le'Veon Bell and
now is the time to do it because Sam
Donald is operating under the early
years of a rookie contract and the Jets
can't even begin to think about paying
him until after the 2020 season so
they're gonna be together for a few
years and I think it's gonna be a good
match that the next best match beyond
the obvious one that you picked because
the coin toss is rigged yes it is rigged
and thank you for letting it berate
Kristen but yes no I
with you that would have been my next
bag it's interesting now it gets
interesting now is when you're gonna
start filibustering and saying this is
difficult cuz you don't know where to go
from here I do know where to go but I
wanted to talk I mean it's awesome for
exam darn a little Evian Bell okay but I
do know where to go well it's down with
the two I'm not totally sure where I
want to go here but okay I'm gonna go
with I'm gonna go with another obvious
one I'm not gonna try to be too creative
here yeah I'm excited to see Derrick
card Antonio Brown okay yeah Derek Carr
is not Baker Mayfield he's not Aaron
Rodgers he's not that but there's more
to this to why I want to see it I mean
first of all it has potential to be
big-time on the football field I know
Derek Carr hasn't been perfect the last
two years but then the 2016 season man
he was in the MVP conversation and
probably the leader until he breaks his
leg late in the year against the
Indianapolis Colts so he does have
ability an Antonio Brown and B I want to
say the court the quartet of Jon Gruden
and I'll even throw Tyrell Williams in
there which was a great kind of under
the radar signing receiver from the Los
Angeles chargers where I go I'm I'm
excited to see this offense and this
combination of teammates all together
I mean Gruden is gonna have what we
heard yesterday he's gonna have 400
plays in the game plan for Antonio Brown
to start the season I mean it's gonna be
Antonio Antonio Antonio Antonio and I
want to see it not only because what can
they do on the field but to the point
you talk about Derek Carr he's gonna
have to handle the personality the
pressures of okay you got talent now you
got to go out there and perform and I
want to see grooms offense also perform
within that so I think all of that is
why I'm making that the number two pick
yeah you know that one is fairly obvious
but I still have concerns about car I
can't get excited about it until I see
it and that this is where and since
we've had big cat involved in recent
weeks and when we have him involved in
the draft he'll come up with something
creative and throws a little bit of a
curve ball something different than the
conventional selection and this was on
my list and I'm gonna go ahead and use
it here my best new teammate combination
is Antonio Brown Plus whoever the
quarterback is after Derek Carr because
I think Derek Carr is not going to be
the quarterback of the Oakland Raiders
come the start of the 2020 season
if not sooner whether it's because they
get collar Marie or it's because they
find something else Mike I don't think
this is gonna work my I don't think
Derrick car can do it is that your pick
the next quarterback Tony rod my draft
best new mate new teammate combo not
that's right into your crystal ball and
make some crap up combo okay that's what
you just done there let me let me let me
quote the great Cartman and say I do
what I want yeah barely no that's my
pick yeah you would you invented pro
football talk and it's your show and
damn right that's right you're mr. big
chest on this show is what you're
telling us right there you see my point
will you acknowledge that there is a
chance I under there it car can't get it
done I do I get you totally that is part
of the reason I'm picking it because
it's best new teammate combo it doesn't
mean it's best because I like the combo
maybe a tricks gonna be the worst well
no because of the theatrics and the
unknown about it and Antonio Brown who's
this crazy personality and Derek Carr
who's you know a Christian law abiding
man there's there's some differences
there that's where I just go this is
gonna be fun I like my quarterbacks to
drive 105 miles an hour and videotapes
yeah you you would okay go ahead here's
where I end this draft
okay I'm going with I'm gonna go some
some love on the defensive side of the
ball here and Sheldon Richardson I'm
going back to Cleveland I mean uh you
know Sheldon Richardson he might not be
a superstar but he's still a really good
interior defensive line and the combo
here is not just the combo it's again a
trio here with Miles Garrett who's
already in the conversation for one of
the best pass rushers in football along
with Olivier Vernon an Olivier Vernon
and I know he was overpaid by the Giants
and didn't live up to all the money and
has been hurt and all that but Olivier
Vernon's a really good football player
he's not like a 12 sacking year pass
rusher type he's more of those one of
those defensive ends at six seven eight
sacks but he's awesome against the run
he's very disruptive that way but that
new Cleveland offensive line was Steve
Wilkes in that system it
all seems like it's too good to be true
and I can't wait to kind of see that
combo of players Garret Sheldon
Richardson Olivier Vernon you and I talk
about you got to have a good front for
so you don't always at the Blitz and
Cleveland certainly has that formula
they need a good name for their their
pass rush for the defensive line they
don't something that does come no that's
the name of the you understand how this
works the dog pound by area in the
stadium yes right they need a name
that's tied into that or so they're
gonna have they're gonna have to have a
lot of nickname crazy the better you are
the better you are the more nicknames
that become susceptible to be applied
yeah all right here's mine and you know
I was tempted very tempted now that
Adrian Peterson has resigned in
Washington to go Case Keenum and Adrian
Peterson they they they come together
they're gonna play in Minnesota won't
that be something this year when they go
there to take on Kirk Cousins but I'm a
big fan of both guys and I'm fascinated
by what they can do together if Adrian
Peterson can keep running a ball the way
that he did last year but this one's
even better and this one's gonna this
one is going to surprise you but it's
going to impress you Nick Foles the new
quarterback in Jacksonville plus
receiver Dede Westbrook who quietly has
become the best receiver in Jacksonville
who went coming out of college and he
had some off-field issues that knocked
him down in the draft there was some
comparisons to like a little bit less
than a Tyree kill type of man Sean
Jackson I think would have been a proper
you you get you get a guy you get a guy
who can get him the football on a
consistent basis in Nick Falls and you
could have a special combination because
look Falls is there now to throw the
football who's he gonna throw it to yeah
he's gonna be thrown at the DD Westbrook
and I'm looking forward to that one and
that one excites me and that's a real
one at that one balances out my kind of
tongue-in-cheek Antonio Brown and
whoever ends up in Oakland Nick Falls DD
Westbrook watched that one
I like that Mike that's that's good
thinking it's creative thinking there I
mean way better than your last [ __ ] pick
but yes DD Westbrook you know - what
you're saying is he's kind of one of
those guys that I think is waiting to
explode onto the scene here in the NFL
he does have some big-time Talent
he can fly and yes he just hasn't had a
guy that can really get him the ball
consistently
he's got that now so good pick by you I
won the draft there's no point
discussing that there was some other
ones on the board though Mandi Ford I
thought you know Dee Ford and some of
the DeForest Buckner and those defensive
lineman for the 49ers or even Quan
Alexander they signed I was excited
thick Bo so I'm waiting for d4 to Nick
Mosul yes yeah that'll be a serious
defense if they get Nick Bose at the
number two number two pick along with D
Ford and the rest of the deal I'm and
they got there already how about how
about Carson Wentz and the the new old
Eagles receiver DeSean Jackson no no
doubt again I think that's a perfect
combination there I mean DeSean Jackson
Carson Wentz his ability to throw the
ball down the field or buy time running
around in the pocket extending plays I
think that one is certainly exciting and
I'll tell you what we talked about duo's
trios how about the quartet Mitch Morse
Josh Allen John Brown Cole Beasley
revolutionising a Bills offense that
really didn't have a lot of help around
their young franchise quarterback you
get some weapons now for Josh Allen yeah
I have quietly they have in sneaky
fashion put themselves in position to be
contenders in 2019 all right recap of
the draft
chris has Odell Beckham and Baker
Mayfield Derek Carr and Antonio Brown
Sheldon Richardson miles Garrett Olivier
Vernon etc I went with Sam Donald levy
on bail Antonio Brown plus whoever the
quarterback is after Derek Carr cuz I
think it's coming and finally Nick Foles
and DD West
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports